the BMW 5-series has been a staple of a
luxury car market for decades the
current generation of the series hit the
streets in 2010 for 2014 BMW engineers
have made a few minor changes in what's
known around the company as the f10
we're going to take the BMW 530 d out
for a test drive the BMW 5 models drive
like a large sedans as test driver
Montes curve
they're not particularly sporty but then
not really sluggish either you can
switch the dynamic drive to sport or
Sport+ for a more robust steering feel
or put the car into Eco Pro Mode to cut
down on fuel consumption if you take
your foot off the accelerator the
drivetrain disconnects it's called
sealing Vega and Eggman death this
option functions well on either country
roads or on the freeway but our test
driver isn't focused today on sailing
he's going to put the 5 30s driver
assistance technology through its paces
in my lemon mattes tells us they've
increased the speed limit on the cruise
control system from 180 km/h dat 210
that doesn't matter in most countries
but Montes gives it the thumbs up says
it's a good function to have when you're
driving on a German Autobahn because the
traffic moves along faster it's part of
a test drivers job to be critical and a
problem with the 530 crops up pretty
quickly Montes recommends switching to
sport mode at higher speeds
he says when he hit 220 or 230 km/h in
comfort mode the front axle started to
shake a little that doesn't happen when
you're in sport mode sport mode is hot
my cousin of his out the 530d can reach
a top speed of 250 km/h not bad for a
car that weighs 1 point 7 tonnes fuel
efficiency is rated at just over 5
litres of diesel for 100 kilometers
but it's hard to spot the visible
improvements that BMW is made to the
5:30
among the more obvious are the LED
headlights and the luxury line design
package option and there are a few nice
little touches that were part of the
overall redesign aqua fun funky manual
Schluter from BMW says it's the most
successful model of the five series the
company has ever produced over the last
forty years the five series has become
the leader in its class by a wide margin
so the task for the design team was not
to fix anything on the contrary their
job was to enhance the current design he
explains the biggest changes in the 530d
were made under the hood and some were
brand new for cars of his class tells us
BMW introduced a new engine for the 518
d and for the v8 550i they've also
developed a number of new driver
assistance options such as the traffic
jam assistant this allows you to sit
back while you're on the freeway and let
the car drive itself up to a speed of 40
kilometers it eliminates some of the
more annoying aspects of freeway driving
and faulty parts of a list another
aspect of BMWs driver assistance
technology may help cut down on the
number of accidents for example by
warning against making a dangerous turn
but not all of the bells and whistles in
the 530d are that useful
buffman monk on the instrument panel can
be customized but not this doesn't think
it's necessary it's just a simple
display says there aren't any proper
indicators anymore he sees an advantage
in being able to change the display to
reflect which driving mode you're in but
he's unhappy that the gas indicator is
so clunky and it could move a little
more freely when you accelerate he says
there could be some improvement there
the priests were artists model was
around 70 thousand euros but does it
really offer value for money
what is it different it's a solid
package as our test driver the great
number of security systems assistant
systems and comfort options add to the
cost of course and one potential problem
for Sales Executives says Mathis and
others who need to keep the car clean is
the interior it has a lot of nooks and
crannies where dust and dirt can
accumulate they're hard to clean maybe
that's something that BMW could fix in
future models on that kuntum an event
where but a nest gonna that's you're not
my and dision that's cancer puts faulty
hushed item